Çeviri: Erman Turkmen
Gözden geçirme: Yunus ASIK
Mehmet Aksel
Girişimci
Benim hayatım hep neyi yapamayacağımı veya
neyin olmayacağını dinlemekle geçti.
Gündelik yaşamımıza baktığımız zaman
hep insanlar iyi bir şey yapmak istiyor.
Hepimiz iyi bir şeyler yapmak istiyoruz.
Hepimiz iyi bir şeyler
ortaya koymak istiyoruz.
Ama bir de öteki taraftan etraf tam aksine
bizi adeta bir şeyler yapamamamız için,
bir şeyleri güzel istediğimiz şekilde
ortaya koyamamamız için
kurgulamaya çalışıyor vaziyette.
Ailemiz, arkadaşlarımız, danıştığımız
insanlar, danışmadıklarımız.
Hatta etrafta olan bütün fikirler,
atasözlerimiz, her şey bizi
yapmak istediğimiz şeylerin aksine
iteliyor vaziyette.
Hayatım dediğim gibi hep
neyi yapamayacağımı ve
neyin olmayacağını dinlemekle geçti.
Annem evin arkasındaki duvara çıkarsam
düşeceğimi söyler dururdu.
Çevrem bu kadar haylazlık etmeye devam
edersem daha fazla adam olamayacağımı,
bu şekilde adam olamayacağımı daha iyi
şeyler yapmam gerektiğini söyler dururdu.
Babam mühendisti.
Büyükbabam ordinaryüs profesör.
Eğer üniversiteyi düzgün okumazsam,
üniversite okumazsam,
adam olamayacağımı söyler dururlardı.
Baskı yaptılar mı? Hayır, hem de hiç.
Ama hep bunu hissettim hayatımda.
Spor yaparken neyi kazanmamın
imkânsız olduğunu,
koleksiyon yaparken neyi bulmamın
imkânsız olduğunu
veya bir kızla takılırken,
bir kıza asılırken
hangi kızın benim için
imkânsız olduğunu hep anlatırlardı.
Devam etti bu, hep devam etti ve tüm
acımasızlığıyla, tüm baskısıyla.
Bugün kesildi mi sanıyorsunuz?
Arkadaşlarım bu kadar hızlı otomobil
kullanmaya devam edersem,
çok fazla yaşamayacağımı söylüyor.
Yaşım oldu 50.
Bankam bu kadar fazla kredi çekersem,
ödeyemeyeceğimi -çok biliyorlar ya-
yarısını çekersem rahat ödeyebileceğimi.
Yarısını çekersem zaten nasıl işi yapayım?
Karım insan ilişkilerinde bu kadar
detaylara takılırsam,
çok fazla arkadaşım kalmayacağını
söylüyor ki bence o haklı.
(Gülüşmeler)
(Alkışlar)
Bir de bir şey daha var.
'’Ne gerek var abi.’’
Arar en iyisini bulursun,
en iyisini bulmak için uğraşırsın,
''Ne gerek var ki abi.''
Uğraşır, yaptığın işin detaylarında
kaybolursun, ''Ne gerek var ki abi.''
Yatırım yaparken elindeki avucundakini
harcar, cebindekini harcar bir de üstüne
güzel bir kredi alırsın, ''Ne
gerek vardı ki abi, aptal mısın sen?''
Hep bir şekilde insanlar
kendi yapamayacakları
ya da yapmaya cesaret
edemeyecekleri şeylere,
sizi de ortak etmek istiyor sanırım.
Hayat hep böyle gelişiyor bizim
karşımızda düşünce olarak.
Her kim söylemişse bir de
atalarımız var bizim.
Bu atalarımızın törpü taşı gibi
hikâyeleri var karşımızda.
Kendileri bir halt becerememiş galiba
--bilmiyorum o zamanları--
bizim de bir takım işler yapıp
onları geride bırakmamamız için
bazı laflar söylemişler
ve bizim dilimize pelesenk
olmuş vaziyette.
''Eski köye yeni adet getirme abi.''
''Ayağımızı yorganımıza göre
uzatalım abi.''
--Ondan sonra ne var--
''Keskin olursak küpümüze
zarar vermeyelim abi.''
Falan filan.
Ve işin daha kötüsü bu yıllar boyu
ruhsuzlar, mutsuzlar ve cesaretsizler
tarafından benimsenmiş ve bu şekilde
hareket etmeye yöneltilmişiz.
Daha da kötüsü olmuş, bu çoğu insanın
beceriksizliklerine kılıf olmuş vaziyette.
Bugüne kadar maddi olarak çok iyi bir
durumda insan olmadım ben.
Benim ailem iyi bir okul okumamı,
iyi bir şekilde mezun olmamı, hayata iyi
bir şekilde başlamamı, onlarla beraber de
iyi bir kültürle yola başlamamı sağladı.
Ortaokulu bitirdikten sonra lisede,
lise 1'i ben okudum, lise 2 ve 3'ü annem.
Annem okulu boyattırmasaydı
liseyi zor bitirirdim.
Üniversite zamanının gelmesi ise
bana hep sünnet günümün gelmesi
gibi hissettiriyordu.
Hep bir yaklaşan, bir ne olduğu belli
olmayan bir şeydi benim için.
Ama sünnet dediğiniz bir günde bitiyor,
üniversite dört senede bitmiyor.
Amerika'ya göndermeye çalıştılar beni.
Amerika'da da olmayınca, yapamayınca,
''Ben bu üniversite hayatını
istemiyorum galiba" deyince,
Türkiye'ye döndüm ve döndüğümde
babaannem vefat etmişti.
Babaannemin Levent'teki evinde, bir
otomobil bayisine vermiş babam orayı.
Çalıştırmaya başlamış, ben de gittim.
Baktı bana adam oradaki.
İşte ''Bu da nereden çıktı
ev sahibinin oğlu'' gibi.
Ama bir müddet sonra mümkün olduğu kadar
düzgün bir şekilde ona yardım etmeye,
mümkün olduğu kadar
benim bildiğim detaycılıkta
müşterilerin hesaplarını tutmaya,
işte ne bileyim kadınların doğum
günlerini kaydedip
onların doğum günlerinde
onlara çiçek göndermeye,
erkeklerin doğum günü aylarında
onların daha makul şekillerde
servis almalarını sağlamaya
falan başladım.
Bir müddet sonra çok çok çok satan
bir bayi olmaya başlamıştım.
Son dört sene Türkiye'nin en çok
satan bayisi oldum.
Bir gün kız arkadaşımla beraber uçağa
binmiş kış seyahatine gidiyorduk.
Gazeteyi bir açtım, devalüasyon.
Varımı yoğumu kaybettim o seyahatte.
Geri döndüğümde şirketteki bütün arabalar
bana bakıyor,
ben de bütün arabalara bakıyorum
ve piyasada hiçbir yaprak oynamıyor,
rezil vaziyetteydim.
İflas ettim.
Ne yapayım, ne yapayım.
Aynı zamanda otomobil yarışı da yapıyorum,
spor hayatımdan pek bahsetmeyeceğim
bu konuşmamda.
Otomobil yarışı da yapıyorum.
Bir parça otomobil yarışı yaptığım
otomobilleri vitrinde
sergilemeye başladım.
Derken kapıdan bir gün
bir beyefendi girdi.
Son derece beyefendi bir adam.
Hatırlarsınız herhâlde ismini,
Tuğrul Şavkay.
Türkiye'nin en kıymetli
gurmelerinden biriydi,
vefat etti.
Tuğrul beyle tanıştık.
Çok seviştik, birbirimizi çok sevdik ve
Tuğrul Bey şöyle bir baktı ve dedi ki
benim cadde üstündeki
otomobil sattığım yere.
"Ya Mehmet Beyciğim" dedi, "Buranın önü
ne kadar güzel bir kafe olur."
Tamam, hemen kafe yapalım orayı.
(Gülüşmeler)
Ertesi gün indirdik balyozu.
Hemen kurguyu kurduk ve ben artık yiyecek
içecek işinin içindeydim.
İşime de çok özen gösteriyorum.
İşte mutfakta da çalışıyorum, bulaşıkta da
çalışıyorum, serviste de çalışıyorum,
hesap almada vermede de çalışıyorum,
kasada da çalışıyorum falan.
Biraz vakit geçti ve ikincisini açtık.
Biraz vakit geçti ve iş iyice büyüdü.
Bir de baktım gayet güzel para kazandıran,
gayet güzel işinin başında durduğun zaman
ve bazı must'ları yerine getirdiğin
zaman her iş güzel iş yapıyor.
Tıkır tıkır tıkır işleyen
iki kafemiz oldu.
Biri Levent'te, biri Maslak'ta.
Bir gün yaptığım spordan dolayı
bir arkadaşımla beraber
yurt dışında spor malzemesi bakıyoruz.
Yani ata biniyorum ben,
at bakıyoruz.
(Gülüşmeler)
Nasıl bizim spor malzemesi?
At bakıyoruz.
Dedi ki:
Benim de lakabım "Yumurta Mehmet"
(Gülüşmeler)
--Atlı Spor'da.
"Yumurta" dedi.
"Bu çok güzel bir şey" dedi.
Bir restorana gittik, çok güzeldi böyle.
"Yumurta." dedi. "Bu harika bir restoran.
Böyle bir şey yap da akşamları da
sana yemeğe gelelim." dedi.
Çünkü daha evvel yaptığımız kafeler
sadece öğlen ve sadece iş saatlerinde
hizmet veren kafeler.
Neyse.
Döndüm benim gözüm artık ne kafe görüyor,
ne araba görüyor, ne bir şey görüyor.
Hiçbir şey görmüyor.
Ben bir restoran açacağım
ve akşamları insanları ağırlayacağım.
Ve elimde avucumda ne varsa sattım--
çok da bir şey yok.
Ondan sonra bankalardan kredi aldım,
şöyle yaptım böyle yaptım.
O şöyle yaptım böyle yaptımlardan da
para geliyor yani.
Şöyle yaptım, para gelmeyen bir şey değil.
Ondan sonra topladım toparladım falan
ve 2000 senesinin sonlarına doğru
inşaat bitti.
2001 senesiydi galiba yanlış
hatırlamıyorsam Nişantaşı'nda,
o zaman Türkiye için ikinci büyük yatırım
ile Nişantaşı'nda bir restoran açtım.
Pazartesi günü Soft Opening’i yaptım.
Salı günü Amerika'daki
kulelere uçak girdi.
(Gülüşmeler)
Tamam mı?
Ve benim hangi tarafından bahsedeyim?
Finans tarafından mı?
Popo tarafından mı?
(Gülüşmeler)
(Alkışlar)
Yapı Kredi'nin Leasing müdürü yemin
etmişti dolar 620 bin liranın üzerine
--o zaman 620 bindi--
620 bin liranın üzerine çıkmaz diye.
1.750.000 TL'den leasing'leri
ödemek zorunda kaldım.
Neyse ilerleyen zamanda uğraştım didindim
falan filan, yine o restoran çok iyi oldu,
yine o restoran kendi kapasitesini
çok iyi gösterdi.
Ama iki tane şey gördüm orada.
Birincisi,
bu restoran bir yere gitmiyor,
bir işe doğru gitmiyor.
İkincisi, bu iş bana göre değil.
Bir iş yapmak istiyorsanız,
şöyle davranmak lazım:
"Homoseksüel değilsen gay bar
açmayacaksın kardeşim."
(Gülüşmeler)
Kendinizi nasıl bir işte iyi
hissediyorsanız, öyle bir iş yapacaksınız.
Yoksa yapmayacaksınız.
Neyse.
Ben, şöyle düşündüm ki,
bu iş bana göre değil.
Ben ailemi kurmak isteyen,
akşam gece birlere, ikilere, üçlere,
dörtlere, beşlere kadar
bir restoranda veya müziği yükselen bir
ortamda olmak istemeyen,
sabahleyin o 5'te eve döndüğün yerden
sabah tekrar 8'de 9'da satın almasına,
bilmem nesine bakmak istemeyen,
başka bir hayatın yolcusu
olmak isteyen bir adamdım.
Derken bir baktım, bizim Tuğrul Abi, bir
yerde bir mutfak ekipmanı satan
bir markada mutfak kursları düzenliyor.
Hanımlara, beylere, meraklılara
mutfak kursları düzenliyor.
İşte geliyorlar oraya,
o mutfak ekipmanlarını satan adamlar
bir villaya yerleşmişler,
bir de düzenek kurmuşlar herhâlde
ve o düzeneğin içinde
hanımlara ve beylere bazı
menüler yaptırıyorlar,
bazı bilmem neler yaptırıyorlar falan.
Ben dedim ki Tuğrul abiye,
"Yahu Tuğrul abi, bu çok iyi bir iş."
Yani ben zaten restoranlardan gördüm ki,
şöyle bir deneyimim oldu ki,
Türkiye'de herkes her şeyi yapıyor,
herkes her şeyi biliyor,
herkes her şey konusunda
bir fikir sahibi.
Ama asıl eksik şey, mesleki eğitim.
Mesleki eğitim konusunda bazı şeyler
yapabilirsek müthiş bir şey yapabiliriz.
"Aman Memocuğum" dedi,
"Sen beni hiç karıştırma."
"Sen ne yaparsan yap, ben zaten
gazeteye bir yazı yazıyorum,
ben pek sevmiyorum şey yapmayı."
"Peki." dedim.
"Ama bak" dedim, "Ben bir okul
yapmak istiyorum
ve bu okul şöyle şöyle şöyle olacak."
''Sen ne istiyorsan yap,
beni hiç karıştırma." dedi.
Peki.
Ondan sonra--
Bu arada tabii ben iflas ettim şeyde.
(Gülüşmeler)
(Alkışlar)
Tabii bizim Nişantaşı'ndaki
restoran iflas etti.
Neyse sonra ben bunu bir projelendirdim.
Projelendirmek öyle hani biraz da,
öğrencilerle falan buluştuğum zaman da
üniversitede anlatıyorum o detayları,
çok detaycıyım ya, onları da
anlatmak istiyorum.
Projelendirmeyi falan yüzlerce kâğıda,
slaytlar, bilmem neler falan filan
yazmanıza da gerek yok.
Normal bir A4'e ne yapmak istediğinizi
anlatacağınız bir şey verseniz karşınıza,
tamamdır.
İnsanları yormaya ve sayfalarca slaytlar,
sayfalarca sunumlar yapmaya da gerek yok.
Bir A4 kâğıdına, "Ben bir aşçılık okulu
yapmak istiyorum ve bu aşçılık okulu
dünyanın en iyi okulu olacak." yazdım ben.
Asıl buraya gülmeniz gerekiyordu.
(Gülüşmeler)
Bence spordaki başarılar gibi iş
hayatındaki başarılarda da bazı noktalara
direkt ilgi gösterir ve onlara
direkt ihtimam gösterirseniz,
başarısız olmak için pek bir neden yok.
2011 senesinde, Dünya Aşçılar Birliği
tarafından dünyadaki
en iyi aşçılık okulu seçildi.
(Alkışlar)
Çok, çok teşekkür ederim.
2012 senesinde, 2012 senesi, 2012,
2013, 2014, 2015 senelerinde,
İngiltere Kraliyet Akademisi Mesleki
Eğitim Kurumu tarafından
dünyadaki en mükemmel mesleki
eğitim kurumu seçildi.
Ama, anlatacağım abi,
bir dakika durun ya.
2013 ve 2015'te, iki öğrencimiz ikişer
milyon mezun arasından, bu sistemden
dünyadaki en iyi iki mezun seçildi.
Şu anda Türk Hava Yolları'nda uçan
flying şeflerin
-sayı olarak da verebilirim-
462 flying şefin 451'i MSA mezunu.
Bugüne kadar 6.192 mezun vermişiz.
42 tanesi Michelin Star'lı
restoranlarda çalışıyor.
Bugün-
bir dakika abi anlatacağım ya.
(Gülüşmeler)
Sahne benim anlatacağım.
Dünyanın en iyi 50 restoranı
olarak açıklanan
Fifty Best Restaurant in the World'de,
5 restoranda 6 MSA mezunu çalışıyor.
Bunların hepsi aşağı yukarı benim bir
şekilde tahmin edebildiğim sonuçlardı.
Yani bu kadar çalıştığınız zaman,
binicilik sporu olsun,
otomobil sporları olsun veya başka sporlar
olsun --ben bu ikisiyle ilgilendim--
muhakkak ve muhakkak bir şekilde
başarıyla karşılaşıyorsunuz,
bu kadar detaylarla uğraşıp bu kadar
işinize özen gösterince.
Öyle veya böyle bazen param oldu,
bazen param olmadı.
Ben hep paraya depodaki yakıt
muamelesi şeyini gösterdim.
Çiçek gibi sepetime toplayacağıma,
yakıt gibi depoma doldurmaya çalıştım,
o para denen şeyi.
Bazen çok yakıtım oldu, bazen az.
Bazen depom borçla doldu, bazen kırmızı
ışık yandı, bazen de yolda kaldım.
Ama hep bir şekilde bir bidon daha bulup
yoluma devam etmeye gayret ettim.
Belki biraz daha az kazandım, ama hep o
aykırı bir şeyler yapabilmenin,
aykırı bir şeyler yapabilecek olmanın
heyecanı hep beni motive etti, mutlu etti.
Belki biraz daha az kazandım ama
insanların o Mehmet’in yaptıklarına
şaşkın bakışları beni çok çok çok daha
mutlu bir insan yaptı.
Ve bütün bu o karşıma çıkıp yapma, olmaz,
yapılamaz, bu kadar masraf mı edilir,
bu kadar kredi mi alınır, böyle iş mi
olur, yanlış yapacaksın, ölüyorsun,
öleceksin, çocuklarını arabaya alıp
bu kadar hızlı mı gidilir
falan filanları topladığım hayatımda,
hatalarım ve başarılarımla,
işime koşa koşa giden,
evime koşa koşa giden--
iş bittiğinde--
ve istersem, eğer istersem, karşıma çıkan
her istediğim, yapmak istediğim,
gönül verdiğim işe seve seve
vakit ayırabilen,
çok çok çok mutlu bir insan oldum.
Hatta bu bazen yapmalar etmeler, şunlar
bunlar hep bana bir kamçı görevi gördü.
Bir şeyi yapmadan evvel hep bütün
arkadaşlarıma, bütün insanlara,
bütün tanıdıklarıma danıştım.
Ama hiç kimseyi dinlemedim.
Bir şeyi yapmak istediğim zaman sadece
ve sadece ve sadece kendimi dinledim
ve sadece ve sadece kendi
istediklerimi yaptım.
Kıssadan hisse söylemek
istediğim şu ki size,
neyi yapıp yapamayacağınızı
sadece ve sadece siz bilebilirsiniz.
Sizden başka hiç kimse sizin
ne yapabileceğinizi
veya neyi yapamayacağınızı bilemez.
İnanın bilselerdi zaten
kendileri yaparlardı.
Lütfen ama lütfen hiç kimseyi
hayatınızda dinlemeyin.
Zamanı geldiği vakit -önde iki kızım
var, onlar da dâhil-
annenizi babanızı bile dinlemeyin.
Neyi yapacaksanız, neyi
yapabileceğinizi düşünüyorsanız,
neyi hayatta başarabileceğinizi
düşünüyorsanız onu siz yapın.
Zaten öteki size hayır diyenler
yapabilselerdi kendileri yaparlardı.
Lütfen cüret edin ve
kendi istediklerinizi yapın.
Çok çok çok teşekkür ederim.
(Alkışlar)